yes it's a long title uh and my travel
from berkeley was a little bit longer
than described i
had
a postdoc in two places um in any case
uh i indeed will give you some sign
conditions for injectivity so this is uh
sometimes people ask injectivity blah
blah blah where is the functor no no i
really mean injectivity if you have a
function from a set to another set do
you have two points that map to the same
point and the motivation is i'm
interested in questions from real
geometry
namely where and when do i know if i
have a system of polynomials if i'll
have at most let's say one positive real
steady state uh solution sorry um but on
the chemical reaction network side i'm
interested in the question when does a
chemical reaction network admit at most
one positive real steady state okay so
i'll define all of these things
as i come to it
before i start i want to say that this
uh the theorem that i'm going to present
about the sign conditions is joint with
many co-authors uh stefan mueller
elizabeth elezanda philia georg
regensberger carson conradi and alicia
dickenstein who's here in the audience
okay um so i think all of the speakers
start by saying that they were
influenced by frank in some way about
whether or not to give slides or not so
i'm giving a hybrid talk in which the
first half will be um on the whiteboard
and then i'll be giving four slides at
the end
so here's my outline
could you get the light on
thank you
so the first part of my talk i'll give
the motivation and in particular i'll
tell you what our chemical reaction
networks um and why we're interested in
so steady states
oh chemical reaction networks
um in part two
i'll give you the main result that's
as i was describing sign conditions for
injectivity okay so part two is a
theorem
sign conditions for injectivity
part three is the connection to real
algebraic geometry and in particular i
want to tell you what is the connection
um to descartes rule of science and why
we view it our result as um in part a
partial uh multivariate generalization
of descartes rule of signs okay so
connection
to descartes rule of signs
and then in part four i have the four
slides that i promised on my computer
and i want to pose some questions since
um all of you are experts in solving
polynomial systems um i want to put out
some challenges uh that i hope some of
you can help me solve
okay so um some questions
okay so let's start
so normally i give an example coming
from chemistry but recently i think in
the news there's been a lot of
questions about disease and ebola and
modeling the
effects and how the spread how it will
continue to spread and so on
so i wanted to give an example not of
ebola but of the flu okay so let's say
example
um the
the model of the flu
um and in particular let's start with
what's called an sir model
so who in the audience has heard these
words sir before
okay good so some of you and someone
have not okay so depending on what
department you're in sometimes you go to
a talk and maybe every month somebody
says the word sir
and in my experience it just depends on
what department you're in
uh i guess in my current experience i
hear the word sir every other week or so
i go to a talk of this form
and fir stands for three words s is for
susceptible
okay i is for infected
okay so infected with the flu in this
case and rs4 recovered
um and so this in general
the fir uh the that's our sir model was
first presented in 1927 but i want to
give a just a modified version so that's
a bit more realistic for the flu okay so
let's just say modified
so if you study epidemiology or anything
this is the first thing you studied at
the very beginning so let's write down
some things that happen when when the
flu happens so let's say that i arrive
here i have the flu and you want to know
are you also going to get the flu
so let's write down some things that
could happen
um so if i have a susceptible person
that's you i'm an infected person that's
me
then um
let's say that you know i had lunch
together and maybe we shook hands and
there's some probability that now i have
transmitted the disease to you and it
also depends on whether you go wash your
hands or not right so there's some
probability where we will turn into two
people that are infected
okay
so this is people getting sick
getting sick
actually so something that was to come
his way down here i want to write s goes
to r this is me i got the flu shot so i
don't have the flu
flu shot
okay and so maybe we're imagining all of
you right there's some probability that
you guys are getting a little bit
nervous and you are all going to go and
get a flu shot um
so maybe a lot of you guys will turn
into uh recovered people soon
um okay and then let's just write down
some other things that can happen
if you're infected then you
eventually hopefully become recovered
okay so this is recovery
okay
and let's say maybe some of you
decide to go home right
okay um but
uh
sorry
is that yeah yeah so usually this is
people who are dying but i decided to
make this a bit more friendly and so
some of you are going home and not
staying at simon's brother sister
okay go home
uh okay um okay but maybe you got sick
and you went home but you were supposed
to give a talk and so you send somebody
else to come give your talk for you and
then those are people who are arriving
let's say zero goes to s
uh zero goes r but let's say if you have
the flu you will stay home you won't
come to give your talk okay so these are
arrivals
okay
uh okay so now i've written down um i'll
submit some by some depiction of arrows
some things that can happen right under
the the simple flu model and what i have
described is that each
arrow only happens with certain
probabilities right
if i assign to each of these
um
what i call reactions uh some rate then
that will describe um
uh how likely these things will happen
okay so i want to call this capital one
kappa two
got the three
four kappa five kappa six
kappa seven and kept eight
okay
and so for example if all of you guys
are washing your hands on capital one
you should think it was a very small but
positive number
okay
because you're not going to get infected
um compared to maybe people getting them
shot okay
um and so what people when they first
wrote down the sir model is to write
down um in a deterministic setting
what are the dynamics that arise from
this how many people will be susceptible
infected and recovered and how this
changes in time and so this is what
people write down
okay so we have differential equations
for each of the three
so of course you could do a stochastic
or discrete version of these systems um
but
as long as under certain reasonable
hypotheses um you can think of this as a
deterministic continuous setting and
that's what we'll do today okay
so um according to the law of mass
action
it says that the um that this says that
the number of times that too susceptible
and infectious person
becomes two infectious people is
proportional to how many susceptible
people there are and how many infected
people there are okay so in other words
the um rate at which this uh the number
of susceptible people will change okay
coming from this one reaction is
proportional to the product
so this is what is described by the law
of mass section it says that each
let me say in parentheses reaction rate
is proportional
to the product
of
reactants so if these this was actually
chemistry then s and i would be actually
what we would call chemical species
they're mixing together in some large
vat um and uh they are reacting to
become two eye but here you should think
there is this big auditorium room and
maybe we always mix together and have
lunch together and we shake hands and
whatever
and the probability that these things
will happen is proportional to how many
infected people are and how many
susceptible people are okay so here i
would write um for this reaction which
takes place at rate capital one
the number of susceptible people will
decrease because they became infected so
i would write this as minus capital one
times s
times i
okay so here's my monomial s times i
times the constant capital one
um and then to write down all the rest
of the differential equations i just go
through all of these reactions and write
and write them down as a sum over all of
these possible arrows okay
so for example for s the first reaction
i already read wrote down the second one
does not affect s
but then i have this third one where
people go home okay so i think i write
minus kappa three s
um and then at the end there's the flu
shot people um so this becomes uh minus
kappa s
times
plus kappa six um because some people
are arriving who are susceptible
and in particular you can see i i sort
of made this example a little bit
contrived in order so that there's
actually positive real solutions right
because normally just everybody will
eventually become sick and then that's
the end of the story but now i'm
assuming that there are some arrivals so
new people are coming in
um who are uh not been sick yet
okay so now let me just write down the
rest for i and for r
so capital one s times i
minus kappa two i
minus kappa four i
okay
and
kappa two i minus kappa five r
plus kappa seven plus a cap eight
okay
and this model is only valid if the
number of people is kept constant um but
maybe in this setting right the number
of people here at simon's is somewhat
constant so it would be okay
i was well okay so you could add it in i
don't think it affects much um the but i
didn't actually work it out um but maybe
i was just thinking that people if
you're sick maybe you would not show up
or i would hope that you would not show
up okay
uh okay so you might start to start with
this system of equations and you might
ask okay now i have a continuous
dynamical system and you might ask many
questions and the um there are many
questions that you could ask and i'm
only going to focus on steady states but
if you're interested in other questions
for example is the flu going to die out
is the flu going to um or is everyone
going to get the flu that's a that's an
interesting question which i will not
talk about
you could ask the question if i had um
solutions to this so i have a trajectory
of the form s comma i comma r
you could ask from those solutions
can i actually recover the all of these
parameters right here are eight
parameters but i have a solution set can
i uh the trajectories can i recover
these eight parameters if you're
interested in this question you should
wait for nikki's talk she will tell you
about these answers okay
you could ask questions about the um
understanding when there are certain
numbers of steady states so i might ask
can you decompose give the
semi-algebraic decomposition of the
eight-dimensional parameter space based
on how many uh steady states there are
let's say in this case it happens to be
zero or one so it's a little bit silly
but in general you might have uh some
large number of study states and then
maybe chalgato will be interested in
solving this problem for me for example
okay so there are very many interesting
questions but i want to focus today on
the question of
okay
when
are there
uh
less than or equal to one
positive steady state
and since i haven't defined it i should
say definition
a steady state
okay
of this system of differential equations
okay
is some uh let's say s star
i star
r star
okay
at which
the differential equations the odes
are equal to zero
okay and in particular since i'm looking
at a network from from biology i'm
interested in
non-negative real solutions
okay
r greater than equal to zero to the
third
and if i wanted to
if i wanted a positive steady state
which i actually do for this talk i want
to restrict to the strictly positive
entries okay
so i could say a positive steady state
is when i disallow any
when any of the coordinates is equal to
zero okay so you see what i'm doing
right i took this system of three
polynomial equations i'm setting all
three equal to zero and then i'm asking
how many solutions do i have right
um and how does this question depend on
the kappas
so who sees how you can easily solve
this system
it's very easy right it's almost linear
except for one uh
uh degree two term right
but uh okay so what should you do what
can you see if it's an easy trick
yeah you could let me try but some yeah
and there's something even easier here
that i canceled out right yeah you can
divide the second turn right i so now
it's linear and then everything is good
to go so that's how you can see that
there's only zero or one solutions okay
okay but of course we'd like to have
theorems where we don't want to just
have to try to do everything by hand or
um
or to just
blindly throw things into computer
algebra
uh okay so that's what we will talk
about today
okay let's see okay so three lines of
research
um so what i did here was give you an
example this is a network right this is
consists of a bunch of reactions arrows
using the law of mass action i write
down a system of polynomial equations
and i'm interested in setting them equal
to zero okay
so people who have studied this from the
chemical reaction network point of view
have
used the special structure to get some
nice theorems about trying to answer
questions about the number of study
states
so broadly speaking there are three
areas of research that have developed
and the first is called deficiency
theory
um this began in the 1970s
uh
and i guess has continued somewhat
since then
um and a basic idea this is not the
focus of my talk um but the basic idea
is that you can compute some a number an
invariant coming from the network very
easily
and from this invariant you can easily
sometimes determine that there's no more
than one steady state and in fact
there's always a unique positive steady
state okay so if i were to give you a
different example
which is completely contrived
i plus r r plus s
if i looked at this network here
what deficiency theory would tell me to
do is to compute something called the
deficiency okay
and i do this by computing the number of
vertices
here it's three okay the number of
components
that's equal to one okay
and then i compute the dimension
of the span
of the three corresponding reaction
vectors okay
um so here it's um two r minus i minus s
and then i have r plus s
minus i plus s
okay
and then the third vector is just the
sum of the other two but let's just
write it to be um clear
two r minus r minus plus s
okay
so if i look at the span of these three
vectors it's a two dimensional space and
what deficiency theory says in this case
is that i um subtract one plus two from
three
okay the deficiency is three minus one
minus two i get zero
okay this must be a delta
and according to deficiency theory since
the deficiency is actually zero then
this system if i wrote down the
corresponding odes would always have a
unique positive steady state okay
so according to
deficiency theory
deficit in particular deficiency zero
theorem
there's always a unique positive steady
state
or in other words if i wrote down the
system of equations then regardless of
what choice of parameters i picked okay
so i could put there are three
parameters here capital one kappa two
and kappa three the resulting system
would always have a unique positive
steady state a unique positive real
solution okay regardless of what happens
i think
um so there's a whole line of research
in this in this area
um the two areas the other two
um topics the other two lines of
research i do want to talk a little bit
about
and the third is the main focus which is
injectivity
okay
so this is where our theorem fits in
and the second line i want to mention
which i'll say again later okay
is the question of well
going back to i think maybe jm asked
this question what happens if i also
included um
the reaction where um people who have
the flu are actually arriving could i
have inferred from this computation
the fact that if i added something else
maybe i would still have the same kind
of result okay so i think of this as
lifting steady states
from small
to large networks
from small to larger networks
and i'll say a little bit about this um
when i do my four slides at the end and
alicia will say more later this
afternoon
more content to that deficiency theory
like is the steady state
stable it's known to be locally stable
in the open conjecture which um is one
of my main research focuses is asking
the question about global stability
because there's a lyapunov function in
everything but the issue is near the
boundary when some of the coordinates
are close to zero
could it actually be the case that they
um go off to the boundary to go off to
infinity or whatever yeah
and i'll show some pictures related to
that near the end of my talk
okay yeah there's much more than i've
described here but from the point of
view of just counting steady states just
counting positive solutions um it just
guarantees a unique such solution
okay so let me spend the rest of my
board talk about injectivity and then i
will
talk about part two and other
open questions
okay so we're going to um a slightly
more general setting than the ode system
that i wrote down here and i just want
to think of any system of
polynomials that has um this sort of
parameterized family point of view okay
so i want to consider polynomial maps um
parametrized by some kappa okay
going from a positive ortho
um to all of rn okay and so one special
case you want to think of is these
mass action odes that i've described
here okay so the setup is
a restricted
polynomial map
because i want to restrict my attention
to the positive ortho because i want to
ask about positive real solutions and
not all solutions in general
um let's say given
by
f kappa
uh comma i
of x
is equal to some polynomial system
the coefficients are a i j but i want to
be able to scale them by some kappas
so let's multiply it by kappa uh j
x oh kappa i j i believe i think i'm let
me double check this
okay x times x one to the b j one
dot dot x and
b j n
okay
uh sum from j equals one to r for
i equals 1 up to n
okay
okay so do i want a kappa i j or do i
want a
kappa j yeah
okay
okay and so how many do i have so i have
n equations okay
and i can summarize the information
coming from the exponents and the coming
from the coefficients okay so for some
matrix a
which is a real n by r matrix okay b is
r by n
and the kappa
has one
uh is some strictly positive
um
uh
sum over all of the possible monomial
coordinates
okay
uh another example you can think in your
head at least for my application is when
these um f's of kappas are those uh
three differential equations there okay
or three just
polynomials
um so the first thing i want to mention
is that
in the setting of these ode systems
there's often some conservation
relations so one thing i'd mentioned is
maybe you want to think of the
population as being constant and
sometimes encoded in these differential
equations there's actually some
conservation relations
so in general
no r is the number of terms the number
of monomials these degrees could be
arbitrary here's the monomial and here
are the coefficients in front of the
monomial and then these are all the
collection of
exponents
yeah these are the b's are the um the
encode all of the exponents in the
monomials and a encodes the coefficients
here but i want to scale them by some
kappas that's what i my theorem will
want to say something about for all
kappas how many solutions do i have
sorry
oh yeah yeah so that's what the title
said generalized polynomials our theorem
is uh works in that setting so i just
said r yeah
yeah yeah yeah there are many terms like
synonyms and things like that right yeah
okay
uh yeah so maybe we in our paper we call
them generalized polynomial maps yeah
okay
okay so note
generally
conservation relations
constrain
constrain
trajectories
of um uh the solution the ode system
okay so if i had some dx dt is sum f of
x
okay
um so i don't have an example like that
this there's actually no conservation
relations in this case but in general um
a picture took particularly looks like
this that
the differential equations actually live
in some lower dimensional subspace okay
so here
if you go back here and i look at these
coefficients a i j okay
if i look at the corresponding column
vectors okay
those will constrain
the space in which this
map lives okay so in general this image
will be a lower dimensional space and so
i'm interested in um
translations of this subspace okay and
my solutions will be confined to those
okay so this will be solution
um to the ods
okay we'll be in a translation of these
the subspace s and in general this might
happen because maybe
the
systems are constrained in such a way
that maybe the total amount of people
infected and susceptible and um
uh resistant are actually constrained to
be summing up to something right maybe
they uh
the number of people that are allowed at
this conference are always some fixed
number okay and sometimes it's reflected
in in the ods
312. so if the number if every seat was
exactly full then this would this would
be what it was okay
uh okay good
so the point maybe if i use another
color it'll be
a bit more clear
is that i'm interested in the set of
study states which depends on kappa
but i want to count them
relative to some specific
translation of s okay so i want to count
within this set um p
which is a translation of s
s
plus some um initial point okay
intersected with the non-negative orthot
i want to count the number of uh steady
seats in here okay so count
setting states here
so this is the picture that i have in
general but not
in this specific example
so
so the question of injectivity which is
the theorem i want to tell you about
starts from the basic premise a very
very basic idea which is that well if i
want to ask when i restrict to the
set p
and i want to know are there two or more
points that both mapped to this point
zero under the map set of odes well a
basic condition for this to be true is
if the map is injective to begin with
right because you can't have two things
mapping to zero unless
there are two things mapping to the same
point to begin with
so i'll write that as the basic
observation
a sufficient condition
we're
precluding multiple steady states
is if
this
uh the odes the map of odes restricted
to p
which goes from p um to the subspace s
right because this is where my odes live
in the subspace f
is an injective function is injective
for all p
and for all uh catalysts
so again this is a very basic idea right
i want to say well what is it that for
um any choice of uh my rate constants
okay
uh i never have two or more points
within some invariants at p that go to
zero well what basic condition is um if
the map is always injective
okay and so what our injectivity theorem
which i'll now write down says is we can
check this condition
using sine vectors
no that's okay okay
oh you mean in general
in general yeah in general yeah okay but
in the setting of mass action that will
be fine yeah
you're asking oh cause you're asking
about the reaction vectors yeah yeah i'm
a little
in the setting i'm interested in this is
okay
okay so let's do some notation
okay so i just want to give notation for
a sine vector so if i have
a vector x i will call this the sine
vector sigma of x
and just as an example
let's say minus 3 to
zero this sine vector is minus plus zero
it just records for each coordinate
whether it's positive negative or zero
um so here's our theorem
our theorem characterizes exactly when
the sufficient condition happens um
and and it gives four equivalent
conditions um
for this
so the following are equivalent
one
um this exact condition happens okay
so we're all p for n for all
kappa
um this restricted map
f kappa restricted to p is injective
okay so this is why we're interested we
want to find some equivalent conditions
for checking this condition here okay
because
let's back up what is the what is this
asking this is asking i have a system of
polynomials and i want to ask for every
parameter so every single um
member of this family of
um
polynomial systems do i have at most one
solution
so part two this one is easier to check
it says for all kappa
and for all x in our n plus
the jacobian matrix
of pepsi kappa of x
is itself injective
on s
this is asking different questions
asking
whether the jacobian matrix is uh
injective on the subspace s
the image of a this is what the i'm
defining is s
the image of this uh matrix a
okay
because before in the the so the
previous one is asking about all sets p
now i'm asking about injectivity on a
subspace f
three
so if i wanted to compute um uh whether
jacobian is injective then i just need
to look at the determinant of this
matrix and so um part three says okay
now let's look at the terms in the
jacobian in the determinant of the
jacobian
so i can write out what they are so for
all um
i so i'll i take subsets
of n
and
subsets of r
okay
of size
equal to the rank of a
okay
okay because remember i'm in a lower
dimensional space that's um
equal to the rank of size dimension
equal the rank of a
um i look at some determinants
so i look
the corresponding sub determinant of a
defined by the
rows i and the rows j
and i also look at the determinant
of the corresponding
entries of b okay remember a is the
coefficient matrix b is the exponent
matrix i look at the corresponding
determinants and i want to say
to make sure that they're not of
opposite sign okay so in other words i
want to ask that the product is either
is either
0
or
has the same sign
as all other as all
other
non-zero entries non-zero such products
so either any time this matrix even any
time that the two determinants are not
the same they should either always be
plus minus or they should always be plus
plus or
or minus minus sorry um they should
either always be different inside or
they should always correspond and sign
if both of them are nonzero
condition two does that mean that the
jacobian matrix is actually an injective
function into the space of matrices or
do you mean no the the linear map yeah
the matrix itself is invertible yep
that's all i mean yeah and then this
part three just says okay now i take the
determinant and look at what um entries
what what the uh
entries in this um
determinant r and they they have this
form okay and what's um perhaps a bit
surprising is that a sufficient
condition is as if all of these terms
are positive or all the terms are
negative okay and in fact that's
equivalent in this setting when i'm
restricted to um the interested in
positive solutions only
yeah
uh and then
uh so let me say that this
uh maybe i
let me tell you part four and then let
me remind you that this um the first
three things we're not our result our
contribution is the next
and this is our contribution
um is that the kernel of the matrix a
okay and another sub uh another
um space the image of b
under a certain set
okay
uh have no
non-zero
sine vector in common
okay so the kernel of a is fine this is
a subspace here i'm saying i take my
subspace s and i look at um
i take all of the sine vectors and i
look at the largest corresponding subset
of um
rn that has the same
uh that has that shares sub uh sine
vectors with s
okay
so i'm saying greater than equal to zero
but i'm only interested in the positive
the positive solutions yeah
all these nuts extend to the boundaries
yeah yeah yeah of course yeah but our
result is about strictly positive once
we have a result as well about boundary
ones but i'm not going to describe it
okay so again i look at two
sets and i ask
are there any non-zero sine vectors in
common between the two sets
and this is our contribution that this
condition about sine vectors is
equivalent to these other three which
gives you a sufficient condition for
having at most one positive real
solution
that's the script that's here yeah yeah
sorry script okay yeah the only reason i
changed because i was afraid the fluke
and the flu example with the s would be
confusing so i mean script s all the way
through
yeah so
sigma is a sine vector so i took look
and take a look at all of the sine
vectors and then i today enlarge my set
by all other vectors that have that
share a sign vector with something else
in that set
so that's the really statement about
meeting certain orphans or yes exactly
it's saying does this set and does this
set intersect the same orphans
non-trivially so outside of the zero
vector
so it's asking so if they intersected um
some orthot non-trivially then this uh
condition is violated so you don't have
injectivity but if they do not then our
theorem says that it's equivalent to
having this nice so if you list the
origins
of the others
right exactly so if i list the orphans
for this and or list the origins for
this dish there should be none in common
except for
zero yep exactly
okay
good um and then let me say again the
parts one twos and the equivalents of
parts one two and three we're all ready
um uh one two and three
okay uh we're done
um by
chris june and feinberg
i'm in 2005 and
will you and
in 2013
okay and then there was some intervening
work that generalized right um to real
uh
to the setting of real um exponent
vectors and so on okay but the point is
everything works in this general adding
so we might as well
work in this setting as well
um okay so
and let me just say in words instead of
drawing out some examples that the nice
the nice application even though this
seems very contrived right this seems
like this kind of condition would never
hold
in fact especially for very small
networks you can enumerate all of the
small networks um let's say you put some
bound on how high you want the degrees
of the polynomials to be and it's
actually the case for let's say up to
five or six
species so uh not just susceptible
infected and resilient maybe you also
have some other um classes of
populations as well
that the this injectivity criterion
uh covers many of the cases when you
don't have more than one steady state so
even though this seems sort of very
contrived
and surprising that this is useful at
all in fact for very small networks this
is actually quite useful
let's do part three
okay so
let's
redo this theorem
okay
so what i want to do now is to tell you
another theorem
basically coming from this that we can
see uh
if you look at these types of results
from the point of view as you would of
trying to solve systems of polynomials
okay so we write down the following
theorem um
so let
a be an n by r matrix
okay and b is
um
r by n
um so let's assume that they're both
full rank and this is under an n is less
than or equal to r okay so let
n be less than or equal to r
but i want to consider matrices that are
full rank
full
rank um so let's consider
for any
y
in rn
i want to consider the following
so now i want to
not have the funny kappas that are
parameterizing my system but now i want
to parameterize um by the solution set
of a system okay so i again want to let
the a's be my uh coefficient matrices
so a i j okay times x 1 to the b j 1 dot
x n to the b j n
okay so now i'm writing down a system of
polynomials again
j equals 1 to r
and i want the solution set to be some
vector i okay so this is for i equals
one of the n
okay so i'm in a slightly different
setting from what i was in in the
previous case i'm just looking at a
general system of polynomials um and i'm
asking um i'm asking questions about the
possible solution sets
okay so now let's write down the theorem
we have here
if
okay so this
part is not due to us but rather to
creation
garcia puente
and frank
um and it says the following it says
again let's look at these determinants
and we can use this as a criterion um
for uh when you can solve this system
so assume
for all j
so again we're looking at subsets
of size n where n is the rank okay
these determinants
determinant of b
sub j
n
okay
again want to say they should all have
the same sign or they should be zero
okay
so either is zero
or
has the same sign
as all other
non-zero
products
okay so i look at all these products i
should either
i'll be strictly positive when they're
zero or strictly negative when they're
non-zero okay
then
the system star okay
has
sorry then for all
possible solutions rn
okay
star has at most
one positive
real solution
x
okay
let's say in our n plus
okay
so looking at all of these determinants
will tell you
regardless of what my right hand sides
are i will never have more than one
positive real solution
and then a partial converse to this then
which is due to muller
and regensberger
um is that uh you could ask well okay so
now we have a condition for you when you
have at most one one can i know for sure
that there will be one um and under the
assumptions so assume okay
that the row vectors
of b
lie
in an open half space
and
for all of these products here okay for
all of these j
sorry
okay
the determinants have the same sign
and i'm going to have a sub n comma j
and determinant of
b
sub j coming in
okay have the same sign
so now we're disallowing the cases where
one of them is zero and the other one is
is not zero okay
in this setting
um so
then i can tell you exactly which of the
which of the y's actually have a unique
solution okay then star
has a unique
unique positive solution
okay if and only if
y
is in a certain polyhedral cone okay and
that's
y is in
let's
say the
relative interior okay of the cone
um generated
by
uh
the
sorry back up
the columns of me
okay so i go back into the um
coefficient matrix a okay i look at the
corresponding columns and i look at the
positive code generated by this set and
those are those tell me exactly the y's
that
for which this system has exactly one
positive real solution
and so let me just say out loud a few
comments about this
and then i'll give you a few slides and
then we'll end
so
this results as i as i see as i've
explained was not our result at all
right they were due to some earlier work
um but our contribution is to recognize
and to sort of highlight the fact that
these results give you conditions for
you um existence and uniqueness
of at most one positive real solution
and in particular uh if you think back
to descartes rule of signs right it
would be really nice um as many of you
uh would hope that there would be some
nice generalization of descartes rule of
signs for positive for for both in the
for the multivariate case
um and this gives a tiny result in
towards um this direction in the sense
that if you look at this
system right and if you look at
descartes through those signs it says
look at the actual
coefficients in your univariate
polynomial and you want to say look at
the signs
and then
then count the number of sign variations
here
we say there is a recipe using the
coefficients to tell you something about
the number of of positive solutions it
only gives you information up to one
right and this is very restricted but
nevertheless most of the results um from
beginning with kovansky and all of the
theory of phenomenals that many of you
in the audience have developed
typically this is my understanding only
use information about the exponent
vectors and not about the actual
coefficients and so here in our case
we're highlighting the fact that here
some information from the coefficients
um does give us some information about
the number of solutions
so now i'm going to switch gears um give
you four open questions since i would
like to highlight these applications um
and get some help from you in the future
for uh for proving more results in this
of this one
lower bound as well by some index
argument on the boundary
should be able to integrate the map on
the boundaries yes
actually
something about a lower bound
like that
i don't know about this but we do have a
result about the boundary but um quite
restricted
warming up
okay very good um so now i'm just moving
to the part where i just will tell you
some four open questions that i hope
that
with your help we can solve
so
another result about the
positive study states is on the other
question when do you know for sure you
have at least one positive real solution
um and so
it
in
in some collaboration with uh manoj paul
krishnan and ezra miller we're able to
prove um uh by actually looking at the
dynamics of the system
that's
certain uh what we think of as inward
pointed networks always have at least
one positive real solution okay so the
picture is that something like the
network on the right always has a
positive real one even though um whereas
ones on the left do not so the
difference between these two pictures is
that
what i do is i take the convex hollow or
what you might think of as a newton
polytoe of the corresponding
reaction network here i've just here
it's a two-dimensional system we have c
and d here we have a two-dimensional
system it's a and b two those are the
two species and i draw all of the
reactions living inside of these
lattices and i ask for each of the faces
of this newton polytoe
which uh is there some reaction that
points from the face into the polytope
so here if i look at all of the edges
and vertices there's always at least one
reaction that points into the polytope
and it might pass through which is okay
that's fine
whereas in this case in the network on
the left if i look at this edge here of
this triangle there's no reaction that
starts on the edge and goes inward so
they're sort of
even though they're somewhat related
they're not the same and we were able to
prove something about the dynamics of
systems like this um
and in doing so we could use something
like a broader fixed point argument to
say okay so for sure inside of
some large enough compact set there for
sure is going to be a unique uh there's
always going to be at least one positive
solution
um and so i want to wildly speculate
that since i'm drawing newton polytopes
maybe there's some connection to
something like a bernstein bound right
if if i gave you some polynomials you
would
many of you would do some kind of mixed
volume computation and tell me how many
complex solutions you would expect right
um and maybe there's some connection
even though i think it's a sort of a
crazy idea that there's some a
connection between the comp number of
complex solutions and the number of
possible solutions but nevertheless
maybe we should try and see what we get
question two
there are some conjectures about systems
of this form
so let me just say it comes from biology
and it's a very common motif in
signaling
and we want to know um
can you please characterize for me the
rate constants
for which this has um certain numbers of
steady states so one has zero one two so
on okay
so it's known by um work of lee mingwong
and eduardo sontag that you don't have
any more than two n minus one okay so
this bound is known but the conjecture
that this bound of two n minus one is
actually um not tight and in fact should
be n plus one and n okay for even
depending on the parity of n
what is this diagram well so this
diagram is like the fluid diagram i had
here so it's a zero plus e reacts to es0
means you have someone of a person like
s a person like e and they come together
and now there's a new person yes there
yeah so i'm just drawing they came
the point is that they're linear
well it's not linear because you have s
zero plus e and those that's a degree
two right you have you know where it is
it's a line yeah yeah it's a line that's
motif repeats yep
the graph is just a chain and um there's
a family depending on n so there's a
chain here and a chain and on the bottom
as well
and so again i'm asking the question how
many positive real solutions does the
corresponding system of polynomials have
and how does it depend on these kappa
and the conjecture is um was known to be
true for small n okay that's the the
bounds come together but recently um
for every case except for when n is an
even number greater than or equal to six
the conjecture was disproven using um
uh
sort of clever ways of moving these para
these equations around but it would be
nice to answer the question for the case
for n that's even and maybe
solutions that they have
oh it's uh instead of uh they were able
to go one higher i think n plus two and
n plus one yeah yeah but not for
anything for n greater than equals six
because the point is they could get n
plus one but nothing better
question three
um
so a lot of times in biology people do
things that mathematicians would find
appalling
so for example this um so now these are
different kinds of net reactions but i
could i could draw for you all of the
corresponding reactions okay but here
these are the kinds of things that
happened in biology they wrote down the
corresponding mass action odes and then
they said okay now i want to know how
many positive real solutions there are
so what they did is they ran many many
simulations of these odes and then see
where the solutions went to but these
are so i hope that all of you are also
appalled
by this analysis of real solutions but
nevertheless um uh
they can draw some nice exam they can
draw some nice pictures from biology
saying okay maybe in this case you have
two steady states and it corresponds to
um one case when your immune system
reacted very violently to the to the um
to the
disease and this case where it reacted
only a little bit but it depends on the
input right depends sort of um what k
what kind of flu you got or something
like that
so of course this is relevant for
biology but i think it would be nice if
somebody
could do
maybe i would say a correct or maybe
direct analysis of the steady states
and understood the parameters better
another approach which i um hinted at
earlier is well in this case you can
use theorems about lifting steady states
from small networks to large networks
which i want to say in question in
question four and alicia will say more
later this afternoon
and maybe this would help us understand
this
immune system model so this system is
quite complicated but it would be nice
to understand which other sub networks
um which are the sub subgraphs of this
of these graphs that actually give rise
to the steady state and in particular i
want to highlight that people in biology
care very much about this because well
what is systems biology all about it's
about putting together a systems
point of view from um subsets okay so
you want to see if i know this component
of the network has this property and
this component has this how can i put
them together and understand the global
picture
so in particular that we have in working
bottle yoshi
we have results that say if your network
has always inflows and outflows so
there's always people arriving at
simon's institute and there's always
people leaving simon's institute
of every type s i r then we know uh a
result of the form i was describing that
if some sub network has um two or more
study states and for sure the larger
network will as well
but i think it's an open question so
this is not the only theorem of this
form there are several questions there
are several theorems of this form
but it's still open
what other sets of
pairs of networks can i lift from a
small network to a large number to to
understand from a small system if i have
three or more city states through more
positive solutions what can i say about
the larger system
and so what one thing you can do is then
draw a diagram saying okay if i know
this small network has um two steady
states and for sure this one has two or
more and so on
okay um so i'm going to just end with
the summary
we gave some sign conditions for having
at most one positive real solution for a
whole family of a whole parametrized
family of polynomial equations
and they help us understand steady
states but what i hope by to convince
have convinced you in the last four or
five talk slides is that there are many
open and interesting questions for
people who are applied like i am
and just to give a example to sort of
highlight how subtle these questions can
be at least
for me when i look at them is if you
look at this very simple um
network here i have
reversible reactions so x1 plus x2 maybe
they get together and they decide they
want to leave the conference and they so
they disappear this is what i'm just
having here okay
and so these sorts of pairs of people
are always arriving and disappearing
from from the institute um and then i
have no explanation for 2x xn
maybe these are co-advisors and now they
have a new student i don't know
um so if you look at this network uh for
any n
you can actually show that for the case
when n is even
there are no multiple study states so
this system if you write down the
polynomials never has more than one
positive real solution
and in particular you can use the sign
conditions i described here to answer
this question here
but then if n is odd
then it's actually the case that you
that it does admit multiple study states
so multiple positive real solutions um
and
for you so for doing uh
big results like this you need to have
results either that says okay anytime
you have a network of this form you'll
always have multiple study states or you
need this theory like i was describing
of saying if i know something about the
small network how can i go up to the
large network
and so the result of schlosser and
feinberg is the first type it says if
your network has this type it has these
conditions and for sure you have
multiple steady states but it would be
very it would be nice to have a better
theory of of such system
finally there are two related talks that
i wanted to highlight if you're
interested in these types of ideas
and if you're even more interested i'm
looking to hire a postdoc so if you or
another person is interested um in
working with me then please come talk to
me later
and i'll end my talk there thank you
just a comment on question number one uh
i think there was a you're asking the
best kind of analogy mixed volume for
real roots or something yeah yeah so
first stops were already taken i mean
back in the 90s was work of guerrero and
also later generalized by stern cells
that there is this issue of uh creating
synthetic subdivision counting
alternating cells and then there's a
conjecture that that would actually give
you a correct bound for the number of
roots but uh
that's that's the first step i mean that
actually holds for certain polynomial
systems in certain coefficient regions
but in complete generality it's still a
very very hard question but there is at
least some kind of yoga for drawing
little pictures and drawing little
diagrams and getting something which
works some of the time very good so i
should have known this
systems that were extremely degenerated
close to being um alcohol i guess that's
sort of in the limit of a
generation so
suppose you've got a system that
satisfies the sufficient conditions for
the unique uniqueness of a positive
solution okay
do the methods the proof methods give
you any hope that you can efficiently
compute that unique solution more so
than you would by solving general
polynomial system is there something so
the answer is generally yes because a
lot of times the systems
what happens is that either directly or
under a change of variables you have
that the
set of study states is given by a
binomial ideal and so then you have a
nice parameterization and
so then you have it
on the nose is that a general theorem
that applies to no
no no
so so in other words even if you satisfy
let's say the sufficient conditions that
come out of the of what you called the
uh i forgot what it was foreign activity
yeah
both that and the existence of at least
one if you satisfy those so you know
you've got a unique solution there's not
no better method in general than just
applying an arbitrary polynomial solving
thing to find it i don't think so i
don't know
i mean in some cases this is like
um i i at least louise told me in some
cases you can use this bathroom
statistics but better proportional
scaling convert this this these maps to
find defined defines or sort of
you know
a point here
some of these can be viewed as there's a
algebraic moment after you're and you're
trying to find the interesting different
pointer to that
bear probably knows that
maybe i'll ask a different player follow
up on this so one method would be to run
the dynamics yes yeah that's what i'm
saying that they did the the biologists
do this yeah yeah oh yeah i see in that
setting you would yes i agree but if
you're using broward speaks point
theorem the dynamics could be it's going
around in the circle and it's not that's
why that's what i'm asking i mean if you
supposed to establish and have that been
experiments about running the dynamics
how it compares to
um so that's what these biologists do
right uh going back to that that's what
they do is they just run the dynamics
and see what you get and then they say
oh i ran this many simulations and i
never got more than four steady states
so this is the answer
there's one steady state you have this
lyapunov function how good is it is
there in this so the in the um
deficiency zero setting you have a
leopard function it's a strictly
opponent function so it's very good
that's a good one so then you run the
dynamics yeah then you run the dynamics
and you sh
the conjecture is that outside that
this should be good to go yeah
generally it should be good to go
all right i actually remember
advertising the type of questions you're
asking so this thing that i did with
george and
luis it was we had our our interest in
this was something from geometric
modeling so it's a completely different
part of a black matter okay
so these questions are they're more
interesting than just polynomials
but they're probably most interesting
for for question health
in chemical networks can you ever have
the boundaries of the positive ortho can
the vector field ever be crossing the
boundary in this setting that doesn't
cross the boundary yeah
mostly it's pointing in from the ground
uh mostly pointing in or along the
boundary depending on situations right
because it could be that if there's no
flu then you stay along the situation
and then you probably have networks
where there's always a little bit of
contribution yes once you get inside you
probably can't can you tend to the
boundary even uh typically it's
conjecture that you know you don't
tangent to the bound but when you go to
this generality where you have real
exponents all kinds of crazy things
happen yeah
but in straight up mass action no
general
yes so this
polynomial map
which
is
does it
doesn't play any role in your arguments
uh
uh we use
i'm not sure if this is the question
you're asking but we definitely since
things are positive we can take logs
right and we use the logicity of the log
but i'm not sure if that's but
we should
system for which discuss are several
results
but not all of this happened
well the reason i'm asking you because
we have some definition of what should
be considered
there's a whole theory of monet we're
gonna discuss afterwards
any
urgent questions
you